so I recently had someone comment on one
of my videos if rice is so bad why are
the Chinese so thin right well the
Chinese are not as thin as you think
from 1985 to 2015 that was a massive
spike of obesity in children and I'm not
even talking about being overweight I'm
talking about classified as obese for
boys it was an increase by 14 times and
for girls the obesity increase was 11x
that's crazy I mean the Chinese once
were considered one of the leanest
populations of the entire world
now it's ranked second behind the u.s. I
wonder why
well because they're eating like
Americans
so yes the Chinese always consumed rice
okay but let's just take a look at what
they consumed in the early 90s versus
right now it was a lot less sugar 1.7
kilograms of sugar now it's 7.7
kilograms of sugar they consumed a lot
more vegetables than they do now
they consumed fish a lot of seafood food
was primarily boiled as compared to now
it's fried they consumed more fermented
foods like NATO miso kimchi now it's a
lot less and the western food and
beverage companies helped shape the
science and public policy and obesity in
China so the recent trends in America of
consuming liquid candy I'm sorry
soda is actually going down so the
beverage companies now are marketing
heavily in other countries like Mexico
and especially China so in China there
is a lot more sugar being consumed a lot
more snacking going on also the amount
of soy back in 1995 14 tons of soy
consumed and it was non-gmo now it's
actually 70 million tons with the
majority of that being imported and it's
most of it's going to be GMO China
actually produces half of the world's
poor and most of the pigs are fed soy so
in summary the Chinese are not getting
thinner they're getting fatter and it's
not because of the rice it's because of
the sugar and the refined carbohydrates
and this soy products are also
contributing to this problem as well if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos